I want to start by saying you have
delivered these great performances the
last few years
opposite these women that have been
doing these you know what I mean like no
I appreciation thank you but what has it
been like because you know you you have
I really liked your work in the Berlin
the bronze you know I Tania you have
this and it's like these are some you
know what I mean you know i-i've been
very ya know I've been lucky to find you
know these projects that I've felt very
passionate about and III think for me
it's just about the director you know
like you kind of start out there and
then and then I mean particularly after
I Tania I was just sitting there going
you know this was such a great
experience and Margo and and the
collaboration and we had on that movie
how am I ever gonna find that kind of a
thing again and then I just lucked out
sort of with this which is really you
know right up there for me in terms of
experience because not only somebody I
mean you know Nicole is it's just that
sort of that person that you know you
grow up and you see them up there and
you immediately you put them on a
pedestal but she was you know like
another peer to me I mean she was so
generous and kind of made me feel very
included right away I mean I you know we
didn't have any rehearsal we jumped
actually we shot my stuff
chronologically which was helpful for us
but from the get-go with her in car and
it was always like teamwork and kind of
feeling very included and and yeah I
mean I like I said I'm I'm happy to if I
can continue the streak like this you
know and and support a great sort of
actress of that caliber and in a very
you know an important kind of female
oriented film I mean why not that's you
have a very cool look in the film I'm
curious what was that like going out and
like could you look normally like this
you are you rocking this tattoo you got
the hair right yeah well Karn was you
know she said look I feel like we should
try something different and kind of like
shave your head and stuff and I was like
perfect I mean anytime you want to
kind of changed things up I'm always
grateful for that because it helps me
sort of you know not fall into my usual
comfort zones and whatever and you know
immediately I thought about my mom
because I knew is gonna freak her out a
little bit and then we had these tattoos
that Karan wanted me to have tattoos and
then I personalized them and one of them
and end up being actually a picture of
my mom that we transferred as a tattoo
and and you know they they I had him for
probably a month so it was it was just
very as interesting kind of like you
know um you know did you ever go to like
Starbucks and just or like a store and
yeah of all this ya notice you were
treated a little different well it's
always fascinating to see how people
respond you know based on sort of
appearance and things like that
but but uh I didn't really know that
maybe I felt a little cooler maybe I
felt a little cooler you know uh
completely one of the things also is
that this is made on a limited budget
limited timeframe you had to film that
Bank sequence which is a action-heavy
set piece I guess you had like two or
three takes to get it right and it's all
in camera it's yeah well she you know
they shot that very real time it felt
like we could they had shot it from
security cameras and they shot it from
different angles and and it was you know
Caron really wanted it to be as
authentic as possible to what it could
potentially have how it would have
played out and then also she wanted that
thing to kind of go down as messy and as
unpredictable as possible and you know
when you see the movie I guess you'll
know what I'm referring to but but
that's the thing with these movies they
get like 30 days you know this this
movie was about 30 days and I mean of
shooting and it's just kind of crazy to
think you know you could you could make
that happen but I think there's a
positive thing to sometimes feeling like
you don't have a lot of time and you
have to show up right away and jump
right in and not spend a lot of time
overthinking I mean obviously for her as
a director it's a probably a crazier
experience but as actors sometimes that
time limit is it can work to your
advantage I'm completely what my last
thing for you but you have a few improv
heavy projects that you've done yeah oh
my god yeah these two yeah right now
with director Amos Wright told that and
I'm just curious if you could just talk
to people real quick about what you know
what those are
yeah so there's a project I did in
Greece it's still shooting it right now
and that's sort of like a weird you know
like the director there calls it a
rom-com gone wrong that's what that's
how he calls it you know and it's and
it's very much in that Blue Valentine
before sunrise world about you know this
couple and then and then I ended up
working on this project here with Drake
James's new movie with Jamie Dornan and
shailene woodley who are probably so my
favorite people I've ever met and again
it's like a very improv if you familiar
with this films like it's all about the
experience as opposed to the execution
and I'm finally understanding kind of
from him like what that means but yeah
it's just great because it frees you up
and and you know in a way you end up
feeling more vulnerable because you're
sort of creating the thing as you're
going and you don't have like the
structure of a scene but but you get
some moments like when you see those
movies that you know like that was what
was happening in real time like that
will be as honest as you you know of a
scene as you'll get you know so it's
just kind of a different way of working
but it but it's really it's been
enjoyable a lot I got to go congrats on
this movie thank you yeah nice
you